I want to find a dish they won't have
taste it and I'm going to deep his
Cambodia to find it off into the jungle
to help cook out a wedding and serve
food that you won't see anywhere else in
Cambodia unique to this tribe so God
knows what's in store first the
helicopter right okay let's go [ __ ] is
hot I'm heading to blue pole near the
border with Vietnam home to the banana
tribe for hundreds of years that lived a
self-sufficient life cut off from the
rest of Cambodia it's my chance to
discover a cuisine that predates the
Khmer Rouge
[Applause]
[Music]
there are 30,000 banana people living
here in the country's biggest wildest
forest
[Music]
I've arranged to meet a local guy called
money to take me to the village of pupal
I'm relying on him to get me to the
wedding feast on time
the brake doesn't work
don't worry how are you I'm good
I'm sorry to let you wait don't worry
okay okay can you come with me to the
village yes please control yeah sure
[Music]
which way left all right draw it right
right
[Music]
the village is another 8 kilometers into
the jungle
when you see
[Music]
[Music]
I'm one of the few Westerners the
villagers have ever seen and that was
quite an entrance Gordon from Glasgow
Balin the banan welcomed guests with
prayers for good fortune and a drink of
rice wine
I finished the light time I'll fall flat
on my face
Paul Paul has just ten families but our
weddings big news in Penang culture and
a hundred guests have joined them from
the groom's village a day's walk away I
know if it's Buffalo snake or even
stir-fried chicken with honey
God knows isolated from the rest of
Cambodia the Penang still use age-old
recipes head chef Hong shows me what's
on the wedding menu super this is done
with pork yeah and it's the village
recipe yeah under Hong's Direction
they're making a whole array of dishes
including soups spicy salads and stews
[Music]
yeah you guys have us strong yeah
strong stomachs yes but the centerpiece
for the feast is the Buffalo
that's the Buffalo for the wedding yeah
he senses something's wrong doesn't our
wedding so important they sacrificed
their most valuable animal for the feast
very strong part of the wedding ritual
involves the bride's father killing the
Buffalo as the Buffalo has been cut up
ready for barbecuing we head off to the
burnings local supermarket otherwise
known as the jungle we're shopping for
honey a huge but there must be thousands
of bees in there with up to 70,000 faced
bees in the hive collecting it is
extremely dangerous and we set this
alight to subdue the bees they smoke
them out smoke they cannot do anything
do you just fly away oh really yeah so
we're gonna stone the bees
yeah mind you it's a big enough joint
isn't it Carrie's homemade smoker the
bravest hunter climbs over 20 meters to
the hive there's gotta be an easier way
of getting honey yeah surely it's got no
safety rope honor if the bees attack
when they've been disturbed they can
easily kill a man so down on the ground
money is making our defenses but I'm not
convinced a few twigs are gonna be much
use against thousands of angry bees
the bees are leaving
the beezly the bees are going absolutely
nuts that was almost an evacuation point
bolt get out of there as we're panicking
down on the ground I can't believe the
honey collector is hanging onto a branch
20 meters up in a swarm of bees he just
made homeless great job they they sting
you mean no no not once
okay Donny amazing with the honey in the
bag we've got a half an hour walk back
to the village but Holmes got other
ideas
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey-hey wild elephants live in these
forests this one was caught and tamed by
the villagers over 50 years ago
how how how
yes okay good you okay yeah that's crazy
yes back in the village the wedding
party's warming up they'll all be
expecting an exquisite burning feast
so Hong gets straight to work separating
the honey and stabbed the bisquits
now Hong shows me his favorite dessert
firstly toast some of the tribes
homegrown rice and this is rice from the
local fields sticky rice when the sticky
rice turns a wonderful golden color
Hong gets me to pound it into a coarse
flour then I pour in some of the
hard-earned honey you don't cook it
[Music]
that's nice like a nut brittle they
taste amazing let them sort of dry out
in the Sun now and they get even firmer
more brittle and a lot more crunchy who
would have thought in a village like
this they'd be coming up with a dainty
delicious little petit four that would
knock the socks of a pharaoh Shay this
honey and rice recipe could steal my
success at the royal dinner so chef the
chef and returning the favor
got very tough now because the meat
hasn't been hung I think it needs a bit
of help I'm showing Hong my take on
buffalo kebabs it's fresh a little bit
too fresh to cook with so when I sort of
tenderize it already and I'll do a I
sort of marinated version so dice is in
big chunks
the soap
after seasoning the meat I simply add
chopped chili to give it a kick
garlic and soy sauce i marinate that so
on
the flavor yeah you've been amazing yeah
the flames and get the hot coal
underneath right as the Buffalo cooks
I'm going to see the final blessing of
the wedding ceremony the bride and groom
anoint their family with a villages
precious ingredient this is the
congratulations to both husband and wife
for the handsome to our thoughts of
people Arden I mean socks by
non-material Connie may wish you a very
happy marriage and lots of children yeah
the ceremony over it's time to eat okay
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls now
we got the most amazing barbecue my
marinade the Buffalo kebabs are going
down a storm
jumped on and he's very good they're
happy and the kids especially you're
living the little sweet the honey and
the ground rice delicious music started
party's in full swing
[Music]
how much rice wine of the gods with the
whole tribe tucking into the rice wine
it's gonna be a long night but I've got
to leave yeah take care take your zk yes
thank you HD thank you take care of are
you
I've had an amazing week but my role
appointment looms next I've got to cook
Cambodian food fit for a king or a
prince and a couple of princesses at
least
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]